欢迎收看赵华
我是赵华
我是艾伦
我们可以想一下
这个礼拜有什么
下个礼拜有什么
下礼拜有放假
那这个礼拜有什么
这礼拜有续决策
好
这个礼拜其实有蛮多压力的关卡
可是下个礼拜有蛮多开心的事情
是的
除了放假
除了中秋节
下礼拜还有台积电的技术论坛
原来是讲这个
而且这礼拜的变音过了之后
下禮拜我们不就是展开个新局的感觉吗
就放完假回来展开新局
加油
好
当然很多人也会讨论说
要不要看是不是中秋节后
会有所谓的光辉十月
但也许像今天的盘面
就隐隐透露出大家快要受不了了
有点弱动臭强
是
对啊
陈嘉良原本4000多亿嘛
突然放了1000多亿出来
因为今天早上一开盘跟昨天一样
要平盘附近震荡
但昨天是尾盘拉肚子
就感受很烂
就今天是盘中就上去了
没错 其实今天尾盘要拉一点肚子
小小的
所以今天是不是有很多中小型股觉得
我不管你晚上怎样 我就是要涨呢
那这样的态势该怎么看
是不是真的不害怕
还有下个礼拜我们也讲了
中秋节的廉价
大家又可以放松一下了
还有台一天的技术论坛
一定会讲很多细光子的好消息
是的 所以我们今天就来帮大家解读一下
这个升息到底是怎么样
我们先来看一下
就是先不讲升息
这个殖利率跟油价
都已经先上去了
这些就是跟升息相关的
感觉上现在你殖利率再高
油价再高
怎样我就是升息
对对对
而且我们现在始朱不怕开水烫
没错就来一起烂
没有没有
对因为川普也说
100%支持联准会
他们自己的决定
所以对他是这样讲的
以前如果是那个谁
那个鲍娥
对对
就是說什麼爛主席這樣
叫你下台
對
現在這個人自己推起來了
就是100%支持
不過我們先看一下
不只是30年期
我們10年期
昨天還講說
這個有創一個新稿
這一次一樣
昨天晚上繼續衝到了
2007年以來的新稿
也就是說
目前看起來
整個殖利率應該都還是
非常在反映
就是目前不太樂觀的狀態
譬如說通諷的問題
沒錯
然後另外一個則是
不只是單純的殖利率問題
目前油價也遇到了一些問題
沙國油管 對 有被預期
恐擴大規模停擺六週
這個是以供給面來的關係
然後就帶動了不然特原油
還有這個習德州原油
持續的維持在高檔
那這個對於整個科技國來講
它就會是一個壓力
因為對於這種高本益比來講
都會是比較不舒服的狀態
這也是為什麼昨天
其實美國股市還是相對偏弱
對 好 那
我只是想到說
像那時候關稅前
我們也知道有關稅的事情
所以股市確實也在壓力鍋中
可是沒有想到關稅真的把大家嚇壞
所以我剛剛只是突然想到說
雖然感覺上我們現在叫死豬不怕開水燙
但會不會真的很燙
可能還是會熟啦
所以我們後續要持續注意一下
不只是利率決策
當然我們現在短線觀察
重點就是利率決策
但其实后面还是要面临的
就是石油价格
持续的往100前高去做迈进
这个整个还是比较辛苦一点点
那我们就先看今晚的状态会是怎么样
那当然讲完之后呢
我们还是要跟大家讲
其实我们台湾目前看起来
还是相对产业非常强劲的
对啊我们又继续有单位国发会
把我们的GDP成长率再往上靠拢
原本11耶
现在来到12了
对啊
是的好
那目前来说当然了
这个看得出来六七八月
這個是各個地方的公布的成長率
那目前看起來呢
11不是是最高的
主計總處說11嘛
對 然後國發會有喊到12
對 那不過呢
通膨啊 它也是相對喊比較高一點
我們台灣央行可能好像也要升行
是 可能可能
禮拜五
就應該知道了
不行吧 現在大家會房貸足啦
還有那些職押股票的
好辛苦啊 對
OK 這個也是我們要注意一下
我們台灣確實也有輕微通膨的問題
好 再来看到的就是台积电OIP论坛
9月23日在美国矽谷要登场了
那里面观察了几个重点
有先进制程类 先进封装类
还有矽光子
没错 所以这一些题材
我觉得像今天的矽光子
有重新发酵的意思
有
对 那先进的这个封装
其实一直都还不错啦
那先进制程我们就看一下后面的
其实创意已经在创新高了
对 所以后面再看一下
有没有机会继续去点高
对 那这个我觉得是一个
對於半導體來講
或者說對於台灣硬體
供應鏈來講的一個信心
是
對 現在有利空
利空準備要出境了
所以要有利多
利多要來看有沒有機會
讓整個成交量也一起放大
是
然後另外一個就是META有擴大資源晶片的佈局台積電9月已經交貨了對 所以目前看起來都應該是陸續還是有一些樂觀的新聞出來對 所以我們就觀察一下
這個連準會講完
有沒有辦法放量
放量要向上放量
那這行情就會起來了
好 行情起來的話
我想主要的族群都很清楚
半導體的先進封裝 先進製程
吸光子 自研晶片
其實都是圍繞在台灣最強項
就是所謂的半導體上面了
是的 所以我們希望半導體
要撐住啊
因為最近的那個
Anthropic這件事情
確實還是可能有些因應的
好Anthropic
不過大哥是仁勳
他有投Anthropic
他有投OpenAI
我都給你們錢了
不要在那邊這隻叫嘛對不對
所以他有說
我們不需要安全監管法規
我們會在安全的前提下創新的
沒錯
然後呢同時有證實
已經美國在這個太空部署武器了
不是 怎麼現在戰場
跑到太空啊
它可以从上面射下来
我还以为是怎么样
跟外星人打吗
所以应该会输吧
其实就越来越像电影情节
你看我们的Anthropy
就是类似那个
也是电影的情节嘛
然后这个打外星人
也是电影的情节
骇客任务
对
所以目前看起来其实
如果是以一个局外人的角度来看
其实我觉得蛮酷的
局外人
对
就是蛮酷的嘛
你看真的电影的事情是在发生的
以单纯一个人类的角度来讲
要来了
是的 但是呢
如果我们以这种
可能我们是比较
有在观察这些东西来讲
其实听起来蛮恐怖的
是啦
对
连太空可能都部署武器
针对针对
一下人类要被统治
一下呢
可能随时都会有人对你射飞弹
然后听起来就比较恐怖一点
那太空武器当然还是有概念股的
包含了就是台积电
圣达科 文帽 莱德光
还有华通 亚光跟药灯
基本上
今天是有反应的
今天蛮强的
今天有反应
开玩笑
像这个之前都是
那一阵子低纬卫星红红的时候
这个没有
的一个上涨的强势的个股
莱德光电跟耀灯
没错
这个是大家可以去把它列入自选的
如果对低纬卫星有兴趣的
可以往这方向去做观察
那再来我们看到就是台湾股市
台湾股市我们直接先看量
量能这几天都是呈现一个明确的萎缩状态
所以萎缩在干嘛
萎缩就要等放量
放量才有方向
因为无量就无价
那我们之前说过
10日均跟20日均全部都跌破
那我们后续观察的重点就是
本周一的低点
至少到今天都有做防守
可是防守过程
我们今天盘中涨500点
那可是尾盘只有300点
因为又碰到五日均线
就稍微有一些压力了
那不过都还可以接受
只要前低没有破
事件性的一个不确定性结束
行情如果能够垫高
站为全部均线
这边应该就迎来一个
短线反弹的契机
那如果多方要重启
这个前高就要做突破
同时这个高点做突破
基本上就是挑战历史新高
因为趁几百点
对 所以大盘我们看一下
明天跟后天能不能来一个
比较激情的表现
那贵买就比较单纯
它就是区间震荡
即便今天它的涨势是比较强的
而且它没有杀毁盘
然后它涨了2.7%
也比上市来得多
所以今天体感其实很舒服的
因为上贵很强嘛
对 那可是呢
大家还是记得
就也不用太兴奋啦
因为就区间整理啦
所以我们后面
当然这边一定还有空间
那上去的时候这种高点
就要收盘价做突破
这个地方只要做突破
这边就是一个新的行情的产生
那成交量呢
如果能够放大到2000亿以上
会更漂亮
所以上市要守前低
上柜在区间整理
都等一个前高的突破
去做一个新形态的产生
那就是要等事件性了
等明天大家200万放出来
没错
那因为那个捍测结束了嘛
我听说吸了几千亿
8600亿
是的
这个是一天台湾股市的成交量
我今天都听到的都是背报
背报没有抽到
还是要上班
抽到也不用上班
会去抽的都已经是有钱人了吧
平白物顾225万放在那里
没错
那我们来看一下联电
联电怎么了
联电很棒
联电这一波
联电很棒是不是
你看这一波是盘整
盘整拉上去之后
这个是涨停板
可以发现我们刚刚台湾股市
是这样向下弯
联电是守住了一个平台
所以目前来说
联电最近的形态
其实都相对比较强劲一点点
蓄势再发
对 跌的时候也跌比较少
那涨的时候它也是有份
那量价呢 这边比较可惜
这四天都是萎缩的
所以一样等一个突破
那突破之后是基本上就是
先补缺口再看前高
好 对 这个是联电
平台突破
再来是看到我们的月光
大平台
没错 慢慢的大平台
就是长这样 结束了
没有啦 开玩笑
就是这个高点还是要
其实这边已经有做突破
但后面行情整个不好
又被整个带下来
它这里创反弹高
那隔天直接跌6%
很过分
所以日月光的股性
目前真的是
比较不舒服一点点
但是我们等一下来宾
会提到相关的一些
大风测时代要来了
是的
成长要加速了
没错
如果短线上来讲
这边就可能要有一些耐心
等形态上的好转
但是它这边就很抗跌因为虽然抗涨但也相对抗跌那就看后续行情能不能做一个明確的多方債勤然後再去創高然後再去挑戰四位數是 那對豐特有信心啦
因為資本支柱都在今年
做一些攤題折就了
明年就是要等營收灌進來
是 所以如果對於長線
有點耐心的
日月光是可以看的
那再來我們剛提到了
就是FOMC會議紀要
原來你是華先生啊
沒有 我是分析華先生的人
哈哈哈哈
因為你竟然
這個大家可以趕快加一下
艾倫說的light
他會這個凌晨不睡覺
看華許講什麼
幫大家來解讀
到底FOMC會議
這個東西有好幾個事情要拆解
不是叫做
9月升息就事情結束了
到底未來10月12月
明年年中之前
會不會持續升息
它跟台股的排面
真的叫息息相關
是關注通膨
還是關注AI的發展
這個也跟後世息息相關
所以這份報告
還蠻重要的希望艾倫認真寫
好 我認真
大家就用力加起來
等著他明天發送這份報告
那廣告回來剛剛特別提到
下禮拜值得期待
台電的技術論壇
要講的事情絕對就是CPO
好 來吧
光通訊細銀黃金時代
1.6T 解放起飛
今天真的是光通訊蠻熱的
也有很多人講說
發現自己焊測沒抽到
就趕快回來買一下雍智
買一下CPU
因為是同一個族群這樣
好 那確實啦
今天的CPU相關的
或者檢測相關的
其實真的還蠻強勢的
對 那我們就來看一下
最近依舊有一些新的題材
在做一個延燒
像高盛有大聲800G
跟光模組的需求
2027年會上修39%出貨
所以目前看起來
不只是需求很大
甚至是出貨也開始順利了
而且現在大家都酷
2027就明年了
是的 其實就是在看明年了
因為也要準備Q4了
那我覺得這個都是好事
800G目前來說
是大型資料中心的主流規格
那1.6T會開始放量
3.2T則是2027年會開始採用
所以這個光傳輸的速度
越來越大管
然後這個速度越來越快
我覺得這個都是正向的發展
另外一個則是中國這邊的
它有一個光博會
1.6T已经成为主流了
从光引擎 光晶片
还有解调器跟光纤材料测试设备
都已经迎来一个新产品的迭代
所以目前来说整个有几个特色
第一个800G依旧是主力
那1.6T准备要量产
3.2T跟6.4T
跟以NPO还有CPO的样机验证为主
这里是主力
这是明年的主力
这个是未来的主力
好 而且有讲到一个NPO
它就比较有机会在2027年放量
而且大家有在讨论
美中虽然在科技战
但似乎并没有要去阻止
中国的CPU
是喔 看起来是这样
都在讲晶片
可是却没有去讲CPU这一块
可见的需求应该是非常大
对 而且它可能
它也只是传输用
它不是头脑
它可能现头脑
但是中间的这些材料
或者是过程
就不会这么大的限制
好 这个是CPU
近期相关的一些利多
那我们就来看一下
台湾股市的相关
光通讯的个股
好 都回档过了
今天符合形態轉好嗎
有一些些有
有一些些還比較可惜
像聯亞就很可惜
聯亞盤中快漲停板
它3,600跌到2,600嘛
跌1,000多塊
對啊 一下就跌1,600
對 是很莫名其妙
可是這一波反彈起來
其實它目前還是一個整理的形態
今天啦 因為尤其又很可惜
它原本漲停後面只剩4.8%
對 那其他的像是光盛
我覺得這個都還差一點點
光盛啊 然後還有誰
波若威也還差一點點
那華新匡也前一陣子跌太重
他出關跌太重了
結果有點落差
剩下我覺得形態都還可以
這個環宇KYA還差一點點
對 其他我覺得都還不錯
我們等一下會一個一個慢慢帶
而且光鏡頭又回來了
是的 連一光真的是很猛
連一光好扯
對
一直往右上角走
台股好像他家開的一樣
對啊
有道理
對啊 連一光很誇張
明明就是第三名
大立光跌了那麼重
郁金光难得来一个反弹
但是他已经创高再创高了
对 所以我们今天稍微来看一下
对 还跟大家讲一下
目前整个年增来讲
前几名都还是非常大的年增
所以目前他们基本面
是有在逐步转好的
好 那我们来看一下
里面其中几位
第一位就是全新
他其实蛮高姿态
是的 那为什么要讲他呢
因为他高姿态
还是一个横向的震荡
也就是他以盘待跌
你看像我们刚刚讲
可能林化英
大概主要二到三家
就全新跟這個那個聯亞
對 穩帽甚至還
近期討論度比較低一點
對 可是這兩家都零化音的
但我們剛剛說嘛
那個全新是
聯亞是這樣嘛
就這邊是跌了一千塊
那全新 全新它是在區間震盪
為什麼你不學回檔過的啊
這麼高檔你不會怕嗎
可是我的想法是它以盤代碟
對 就是不肯下車嘛那不肯下車就是等軍線跟商等新的一波動能進来所以我觉得全新在这个位置上你看这边是碰月线新高所以月线要来了
那停顺点也很好抓
就是这个大量这边
这个低点跟这个低点
如果没有做跌破
其实我觉得就可以
让它在这边横盘震荡
等一个新高
那如果需要节省一些时间的
有创高再来追就好了
所以全新我觉得现在形态很强
虽然是创新高在高涨震荡
好再来另外一个呢
就是前顶
好 潜顶算厉害的了
是的
这一波潜顶算猛的
潜顶也是有说
有接到辉达的那个订单
我以前记得潜顶
都是那种50块而已
那个时候跟比价
就是潜顶跟仲达
对 然后现在已经是250了
对 他这一波
好 这个潜顶
我们这个价格修正一下
265耶
没错
50块变265了
是的
从这边算就好
好
就印象里面
百元以下的股票
没错 潜顶这一波
其实这一波反弹的趋势
其实是算强劲的
甚至比华信光那些都来得强
对 那目前来讲
我们近期可以发现
它股价在这边
做一个横盘的震荡
所以我觉得这里只要大量高点
去跟着做突破
这应该前高做突破之后
就是再往前面高点去做买进
所以前景来讲
我觉得这一波
其实形态上也都相对是健康的
我们就找那种
相对比较健康的形态
那再来看到另外一个
就是这个重达KY
位阶相对就好像比较低
今天第一位接著其實還蠻多
就拉一個漲停板
對 其實有很多
環宇KY 對
然後其實還有其他都有漲停板
什麼瑞生光電
瑞生光電有嘛
好 它不是CPU
不好意思
不是這個光電
東點光電
好的 OK
我們來看一下
仲達其實最近也在抽籤
今天最後一天
對 那抽籤的過程中
就有放量去做進攻了
那仲達我覺得這個型態
我也蠻喜歡的
虽然它曾经跌破了上升趋势线
这边跌破掉
可是今天是站上了下降趋势线
然后一口气站回全部均线
然后今天又出一个量
所以在这个状态之下
我觉得至少这里的低点
应该短期内就不会再跌破
那大家就可以去关注一下
如果我进场停顺点抓这里
那看能不能启动一波
创高的新行情
好 它是现增
现增的话通常缴完款之后
就看看是不是之后不被这个扰乱了
现在只要募资的都会有点压力
是的 所以已经尾声了
尾声就看有没有机会来做一个发动
另外整个营收也还不错
年增100%
单月的营收有跳升了
所以应该是反映整个高速光通讯的产品
有拉货的
这个是后续大家可以好好去注意一下的
一个低位接转强
再来另外一个就是我们的友达
超级便宜
对
凶啦
60几块
是
因为它之前是长输群创嘛
对
但这一波他的形态
是不是比群创还要强
是的 因为前一阵子
可能上半年在涨群创的时候
讲的题材只有群创有
群创就是有CPU
然后也有跟台积电的合作
对 然后又卖厂
对 那下半年呢
友达也在做一样的事情
友达又有厂可以卖啊
是的 这个
对 他最近也在做
他的资产的减肥
对 是整个的状态
都在规模变小
因为股价这样可能比较拉
比较明确一点
那相关的整个在半导体展
有秀出了整合RDL封装
光学偶合的技术
里面有相关的CPU
就是低功耗
而且可以量产的
目前来说
其实就也切入台积电相关的供应链
当然有在证实
但坊间已经
没错
把他们撮合了
是的
所以继群创之后呢
反而因为友达这一波
它前面涨比较少
那这里反而是它股性
比较活泼一点点
当然今天群创也不错
涨了4%
不过形态上就有些落差
因为群创可能连季线都还没站上
那我们来看一下
友达前一阵子是来到了盘中的新高
然后也是前一波的高点
所以这边是套牢区
那套牢区就拉了一个上引线
那上引线之后
刚好伴随大盘行情比较震荡一点
它就一度回测到了
我觉得上还不错的位置
就是原本是压力区
这是大量嘛
原本是压力区
然后呢
站上之后转为支撑区的地方
所以在今天有拉起来
我觉得都还算健康
那当然五日均线没有站上
我觉得有点可惜啦
所以在这边的行情
都还是一个N字型
那接下来
这个是新的N字型
所以只要再做一个
带量供给
这边行情应该就是
要准备去创新高
或者是说
先挑战前高
再挑战创新高
这个目前我觉得
都值得期待
然后筹码目前
有去看了一下
其实是比群创
稍微来得健康一点点
对 所以我觉得
这边有阻力在这边蹲
大家可以不妨去
多关注一下
有没有机会
再拉一个新的形态
好 而且友达的空单
但我记得是不少的
是
可能也有酝酿看会不会有点嘎空
其实以前面板双火空单真的多
就看他们没有啦
但是拉上来的话
可能也会有嘎空跟行情
对
好 所以如果需要今天节目
所有的图卡资料的话
欢迎订阅一下我们
赵华艾伦说的YouTube频道
我们每一集都会把这些图卡
免费放在首页有一个贴文栏
点进去就可以做下载
慢慢的研读